servus es geht zunächst willkommen zur
fünften folge der gay games wie sind
weiter fleißigen provozieren ich immer
noch maxit rechnungen deswegen mit dem
kranken account plus ein mensch auf dem
stürmen des platzes noch freiwilligen
change für dich du wirst heute im f1
modus spielen energie teams und dort ok
f1 fotos die change von krankhafter last
allerdings auf komplette runde golf
erstmal waffen müssen die waffen ja klar
das kannst du alles machen was du machen
musst kannst ob er drücken komplett ohne
alles gut gelungen löschen was du kannst
immer auf drucken wenn du so kurz in den
tag
weiter hinten das gute ist dass er nicht
weiß zeit meine zeit ist die irgendwann
schaden einfach das laufen so
interessant wird hier in alter sollte
man heute auch mal warum diese menschen
nicht versorgen
ja eigentlich schon jetzt einfach random
aber hat er hat ja auch gar nichts der
titel geht
zusätzlich zu einem
egal warum macht ihr das der behinderte
schätze aufnahmen haben ja okay du bist
lustig und grün und co
jetzt wies dies entschieden du bist so
na ja und jetzt ich habe jetzt kann es
mit hotkeys machen uns schon auf e books
ist nach dem siebten platz
oder kommt ein puffer glaube lauf
keine ahnung ich habe keine ahnung ich
mache nicht raus raus kannst du nicht
hoch springen
nein das ist zu hoch
ok direkt weiter machen hier ja bereits
das war das war richtig knapp leute die
die sachen starten oder kannst du jetzt
könnte
egal ob du da bist aber da hatte ich mal
auf 16 51 minuten heraus laut auch schon
mal wahrscheinlich geht es den instant
los wurde gefixt
die leute das ist alter seiner machen an
einer heftigen protesten challenge alter
und wohl die kisten nicht aber dass wir
schnell sind das wirklich die einzige
möglichkeit die du hast mit hotkeys
arbeiten einzige land ist natürlich das
ist natürlich geil
im normalen gold april mit nuggets
machen konnte dass er noch gehälter von
zehn obama voraus
diese runde es geht schon das geht schon
besser auf ihre ich selber auf einfachen
super ich liebe diese menschen haben
ich weiß wenn ich jetzt kannst du immer
gucken schnell sieht mir auf den sack
der cracker ist sozusagen aufgeführt
jetzt wird auch noch roger kusch und
airbus in seine richtung oberkassel
einfach komplett ausziehen der vereins
mutter musste ein bisschen weißen hai
also abwehrtaktik gelegenen gebieten
löschen guck mal das ist gar nicht
irgendwo dann aber noch einen okay das
war kein kopfweh reingesteckt hat nie im
leben
du hast keine ahnung vom herzlosen 1
halbzeit ich mich verarschen bis du mich
verarschen
du wirst ja 57 oder wo gott ist einfach
ne das ist ein richtiger hardcore
cronewitz elf mann hat einfach kein
futter kann der kann im e modus immer
schauen wo die royal nächste gehört als
nächste gegner gesehen
wir leben hier in diesem team
er ist super alles klar geregelt wo
kannst du jetzt einfach erwartet nächste
gegessen hatten die food gehen scheiße
die hatten keine punkte aber schnell ich
nicht sondern
aber ich brauche das auch betrieben die
challenge mode des krieges management
welcher weniger schaffte er sich
ausgedacht tatsächlicher also um
mittlerweile ein bisschen kämpfen sie
mit ihren mitarbeitern kann man so ganz
kleines bisschen ein bisschen navigieren
aber das ist richtig du kannst dich
mutter als auch rechts klicken auf ihn
reagiert hier steht das jetzt immer noch
gern noch ein punkt
bis 18
vielen herzlichen ich richtig richtig
lecker nicht dass das schlimmste dieser
change ist es mir einfach nicht recht
das ist richtig hardcore changes könnte
eine runde bitte endlich eine runde
werden ja ja ja aber
change ist heute schwierig dass man
seine herzen ich sehen kann das macht
die ganze sache immer noch mal richtig
total okay wir haben jetzt vier herzen
leute jetzt wissen richtig leid aber
wenn ihr leben gerettet
oder den perfekt gewesen komm schon ein
paar kalter wir sind down down schade
also weltkrieg gefallen hat dann lass
einen daumen nach oben da weiter die
handicaps in die kommentare schreiben
ihr business läuft und ja wir sind
heftchen produzieren ich bin falls ihr
das seht jetzt gerade auf einem boot in
berlin
also schaut euch grüße euch meine
familie links ab dann seht ihr
vielleicht ein bisschen was ja
vielleicht auf twitter schreibe ich dir
eine andere nachricht
und natürlich keine kenntnisse der
beschreibung nächsten